(man) TONIGHT,
FIVE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE NEXT BIG BUSINESS IDEA
WILL ENTER THE SHARK TANK...
(making whooshing noise)
SEEKING THE FINANCIAL BACKING
TO MAKE THEIR DREAMS COME TRUE.
HAVE YOU HAD SUCCESS?
I'VE HAD HUGE SUCCESS.
REALLY? GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE.
I'VE SOLD TEN MILLION OF 'EM.
WHOA.
THE SHARKS ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT IDEA.
YOU WAIT FOR PEOPLE TO DIE?
IT'S JUST DOWNRIGHT FREAKY.
THERE'S NEVER
A BETTER TIME TO UPSELL
THAN WHEN A FAMILY
IS STRICKEN WITH GRIEF.
BUT FIRST, THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
IT'S A UNIQUE IDEA.
THERE'S NO QUESTION.
THE QUESTION IS,
IS IT A GOOD IDEA?
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
ROBERT, I DON'T WANT YOU
TO THINK OF ME AS COLD,
BUT WHAT DO WE NEED
DAYMOND FOR?
YOU GONNA LET HIM
SCREW ME LIKE THAT?
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
IS A VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN
IS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
WHO TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO AN EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
KEVIN HARRINGTON
IS THE KING OF INFOMERCIALS.
HIS GENIUS MARKETING
OF PRODUCTS
HAS AMASSED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SALES.
DAYMOND JOHN
TURNED RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION.
AND ROBERT HERJAVEC,
A TECHNOLOGY TYCOON
WHO SOLD HIS INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS CACTUS JACK,
A LIFELONG ENTREPRENEUR
WITH A NEW PRODUCT TO PITCH.
♪♪
HOWDY! I'M CACTUS JACK!
WELCOME TO IOWA!
THIS IS WHERE MY HEART IS.
YOU KNOW,
YOU MIGHT LOOK AROUND HERE
AND THINK
IT'S A LITTLE BIT MUCH,
BUT IN THE WORLD
CACTUS JACK LIVES IN,
TOO MUCH ISN'T EVEN
A GOOD START.
MY NAME IS JACK BARRINGER.
EVERYBODY CALLS ME CACTUS JACK.
I'M 65 YEARS OLD.
AND MY ONE CLAIM TO FAME
IS I'VE NEVER HAD A JOB.
ALL I DO IS CREATE PRODUCTS
AND BRING IT TO MARKET.
I'VE INVENTED CLEANING PRODUCTS,
FISHING LURES,
ARM WRESTLING MACHINES,
ALL DIFFERENT KINDS OF THINGS.
I'M A COUNTRY BOY FROM IOWA.
I NEVER STARTED OUT THINKING
THAT I WAS GONNA BE
AN ENTREPRENEUR.
NOW I'VE GOT DOZENS AND DOZENS
OF PRODUCTS ON THE MARKET.
MY WIFE EMMY AND I,
WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER 46 YEARS,
AND SHE'D BE THE FIRST
TO TELL YA
IT'S BEEN A PRETTY WILD RIDE.
I'VE MADE MILLIONS
AND I'VE ALSO LOST MILLIONS.
THE REASON THAT I'M LOOKING FOR
AN INVESTMENT FROM THE SHARKS
IS, VERY HONESTLY,
I'VE TAKEN MY RISKS ALL MY LIFE.
I WENT BANKRUPT YEARS AGO,
AND FRANKLY, I DON'T WANT
TO GO THROUGH THAT AGAIN.
YEAH‐HA!
I'M REALLY HOPING
THAT THEY'RE GONNA GET ON BOARD.
♪♪
MY NAME'S CACTUS JACK.
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER KELLY.
SHE'S A PERSONAL FITNESS
TRAINER.
AND I INVENTED A NEW PRODUCT
FOR FITNESS CALLED THE BODY JAC.
I'M, UH, LOOKING FOR
A $180,000 INVESTMENT,
AND I WANNA GIVE UP
20% OF THE COMPANY FOR THAT.
I WENT TO, UH, MY DOCTOR HERE
A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
AND I'VE ALWAYS HAD A PROBLEM
WITH HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE.
TO GET THE WEIGHT DOWN,
HE WANTED ME TO GO HOME
AND DO PUSH‐UPS.
AND SO I WENT HOME,
GOT ON THE FLOOR,
AND STARTED DOING PUSH‐UPS.
I GOT ABOUT A HALF‐ONE IN,
AND I COLLAPSED.
I'M 65 YEARS OLD,
WEIGH 260 POUNDS.
AND I JUST COULDN'T
DO PUSH‐UPS.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS HAVE
MY DAUGHTER GET ON HERE QUICK,
AND WE'LL JUST GIVE YOU A QUICK
DEMONSTRATION HOW IT WORKS.
WHAT IT HAS HERE
IS A SERIES OF THESE BANDS.
AND THERE'S DIFFERENT WEIGHTS
ON THOSE THINGS.
AND SO JUST BY SIMPLY CHANGING
THE BAND SYSTEM ON THIS THING,
YOU CAN GET EITHER 100 POUNDS
OR 125, 150.
YOU WORK‐‐
SO THE HEAVIER THE WEIGHT,
THE EASIER THE PUSH‐UP?
EXACTLY.
JACK, YOUR DAUGHTER LOOKS LIKE
SHE DOESN'T REALLY NEED
MUCH OF A WORKOUT,
BUT YOU REALLY LOOK LIKE
YOU NEED A WORKOUT.
HAVE YOU BEEN WORKING OUT
ON THIS AND LOSING WEIGHT?
NO, I HAVEN'T.
THIS IS THE PROTOTYPE.
JACK, ARE YOU PLANNING ON BEING
THE PITCHMAN FOR THIS DEVICE?
NO. NO, WE WILL...
(O'Leary laughs)
DO I LOOK LIKE A... (chuckles)
(O'Leary) NO.
THAT'S WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT.
(laughs) NO.
WHAT ARE THOSE THINGS? ARE THEY
PATENTS? IS THAT WHAT YOU GOT?
YES. ALL OF THESE
ARE PATENTS OF MINE,
AND I FUNDED
ALL MY PROJECTS.
DID MOST OF THOSE SELL WELL?
VERY WELL.
JACK, WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO PRODUCE THAT,
AND WHAT DOES IT COST, OR WHAT
WOULD YOU INTEND TO SELL IT FOR?
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT FOR RIGHT
AROUND‐‐BETWEEN $20 AND $30,
WHOLESALE OUT OF CHINA.
IT'LL COME OUT
ANYWHERE FROM $89 TO $129.
JACK, I SEE ANOTHER
WORKOUT DEVICE ON THE FLOOR.
ALONG WITH
ALL THE OTHERS I'VE SEEN,
AND I ASK MYSELF,
WHAT'S SPECIAL ABOUT THIS?
AND THE ANSWER IS‐‐LET'S BE
HONEST WITH EACH OTHER‐‐NOTHING.
EVERY GUY AND HIS DOG
HAS SOMETHING
THEY WANNA SELL YOU
IN FITNESS.
WHAT MATTERS IS,
CAN YOU TIE A HUGE NAME TO IT?
CAN YOU GET
A HUGE BUDGET TO PROMOTE IT?
CAN YOU GET OUT THERE
AND GET SOME MARKET SHARE?
ALL OF THAT COSTS MONEY.
LOTS AND LOTS OF MONEY.
YOU EVER DONE THIS BEFORE?
I HAVE DONE IT BEFORE.
HAVE YOU HAD SUCCESS?
I'VE HAD HUGE SUCCESS.
REALLY? GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE.
I INVENTED THE WORLD'S FIRST
TABLET ALL‐PURPOSE CLEANER.
I HAD IT MADE TO LOOK LIKE
A .45 CALIBER BULLET.
I PACKAGED IT
IN AMMUNITION BOXES.
I CALLED IT
CACTUS JACK'S 1‐SHOT.
DID YOU SELL ANY?
I'VE SOLD
TEN MILLION OF 'EM.
HOW MUCH MONEY DID YOU MAKE?
SEVERAL MILLION.
SO WHY ARE YOU HERE
ASKING FOR $180,000
IF YOU MADE SEVERAL MILLION?
WELL, I'VE TAKEN MY RISKS.
I WAS A MILLIONAIRE
BY THE TIME I WAS 32 YEARS OLD,
AND I WAS FLAT BROKE
BY THE TIME I WAS 38.
THAT'S THE GAME THAT I PLAY.
I'M A RISKTAKER,
AND THE FAMILY...
HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS
ALL THEIR LIFE.
UP, DOWN, UP AND DOWN.
I'M AN ENTREPRENEUR.
I GO WITH THIS PRODUCT.
YOU'RE NOT JUST INVESTING
IN THE BODY JAC.
I WANT YOU TO INVEST
IN CACTUS JACK,
AND I HOPE ONE OF YOU DECIDE
TO HELP US WITH IT.
(O'Leary) YOU KNOW, JACK,
I'VE HAD A LOT OF PARTNERS
IN MY LIFE, DONE A LOT OF DEALS.
BUT I'VE LEARNED ONE LESSON
THAT MATTERS‐‐
YOUR PARTNER HAS TO HAVE
SKIN IN THE GAME,
BECAUSE THE ONLY THING
THAT MATTERS IS MONEY.
I HAVE $27,000 IN THE GAME.
YEAH, BUT YOU WANT $180,000.
THAT RATIO DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
I SEE I HAVE ALL THE RISK,
AND YOU'VE GOT ALL THE UPSIDE.
I DON'T LIKE
THOSE KIND OF DEALS.
I'M OUT.
THE DOTS DON'T CONNECT
FOR ME.
IF YOU HAVE THE KIND OF MONEY
YOU'VE TOLD US YOU HAVE,
YOU SHOULD
BE FUNDING THIS YOURSELF.
WHY GIVE UP 20% OF THE BUSINESS
WHEN YOU CAN HAVE 100% OF IT?
IT DOESN'T ADD UP FOR ME.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
(Harrington) UM, CACTUS,
I LOVE THE FITNESS CATEGORY.
IT'S HUGE. I MEAN, IT'S MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF UNITS.
AND NOT EVERYBODY CAN DO
THESE OTHER PUSH‐UPS.
THIS IS WHERE
I'M WRESTLING WITH THE DEAL.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR $180,000.
I COULD SEE MAKING...
A $90,000 INVESTMENT
IN THIS PROJECT.
I WANT HALF THE COMPANY.
BUT YOU NEED TO CONVINCE
ONE OTHER SHARK TO MATCH THAT
TO GET A DEAL DONE,
OR THERE IS NO DEAL.
THIS IS NOT A PRODUCT.
IT'S A CATEGORY.
I KNOW HOW TO MAKE
THESE THINGS HAPPEN,
AND I WANT YOU
TO GIVE ME A SHOT AT IT.
COULD I DO SOMETHING?
I'D LIKE TO INVEST THE $90,000,
BUT A BIG CONTINGENCY‐‐
AND ONE I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE REALLY ABLE TO MEET‐‐
I SEE YOU AS A GREAT SALESMAN
FOR THIS,
BUT THAT GUT IS IN THE WAY.
SO I'D LIKE
THE CONTINGENCY TO BE
THAT YOU TRY
YOUR NEW MACHINE OUT,
YOU LOSE 30 POUNDS AND TAKE
PHOTOS BEFORE AND AFTER‐‐
LET ME GET THIS RIGHT.
THIS GUY HAS TO LOSE 30 POUNDS.
HE'S GOTTA LOSE
THE CACTUS JACK GUT
TO GET THE 90 GRAND
FROM BARBARA.
CACTUS, I'M IN FOR $90,000.
BARBARA'S IN FOR $90,000.
WE OWN 50% OF THE COMPANY.
YOU HAVE TO LOSE 30 POUNDS.
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
♪♪
KEVIN HARRINGTON AND BARBARA
HAVE OFFERED CACTUS JACK
$180,000
FOR 50% OF HIS COMPANY,
BUT THERE'S ONE BIG CATCH.
I'D LIKE THE CONTINGENCY TO BE
THAT YOU TRY
YOUR NEW MACHINE OUT,
YOU LOSE 30 POUNDS AND TAKE
PHOTOS BEFORE AND AFTER.
CACTUS, DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
WAIT A MINUTE.
I'M INTERESTED
IN THE CACTUS JACK COMPANY.
I'M NOT INTERESTED
IN THAT ONE PIECE
BECAUSE THEN YOU COME OUT
WITH A PILL TOMORROW
AND A BETTER PILLOW
THE NEXT DAY, AND I‐‐
I MAY NOT HAVE
NONE OF THAT.
I WANT TO BE
IN THE CACTUS JACK BUSINESS.
I WILL GIVE YOU THE $180,000
FOR 50% OF THE COMPANY,
BUT I WANT 50%
OF EVERYTHING UP THERE AS WELL.
NOW WHY WOULD HE TAKE THAT DEAL,
DAYMOND? IT MAKES NO SENSE.
'CAUSE WITH MY DEAL, HE DOESN'T
HAVE TO LOSE 30 POUNDS.
CACTUS, I NEED AN ANSWER,
OR I'M GONNA TAKE MY OFFER
OFF THE TABLE.
I NEED AN ANSWER
ON MY OFFER.
WHICH WAS
THAT THE TWO OF YOU
PUT UP $90,000 APIECE‐‐
AND YOU LOSE 30 POUNDS.
I LOSE 30 POUNDS.
CACTUS JACK, HE'S YOUR MAN.
IF HE CAN'T DO IT,
NO ONE CAN.
(laughs)
YOU'RE ON!
I'LL TAKE YOUR DEAL.
(Barbara) WHOO!
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. GOOD JOB.
GIVE ME A HIGH.
GIVE ME A LOW.
(Barbara laughs)
WE'LL GET IT BACK.
LET'S GO MAKE SOME DOUGH.
(O'Leary)
I GOT NEWS FOR YOU GUYS.
THERE'S NOT A CHANCE IN HELL
HE'S LOSING 30 POUNDS.
THIS DEAL'S NEVER GONNA HAPPEN.
THE 30 POUNDS IS GONNA
KEEP IT OFF THE TABLE FOREVER.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SHOW YOU
MY SKINNY CACTUS JACK.
YEAH. LET'S SEE THAT.
MY DAD INFLUENCED ME
WITH BUT ONE QUOTE.
HE SAID, "YOU CAN TRADE HOURS
FOR DOLLARS,
OR YOU CAN TRADE IDEAS
FOR MILLIONS."
GUESS WHICH ONE I CHOSE.
♪♪
NEXT UP IS IRINA BLOK,
WHO BELIEVES SHE'S CREATED
THE NEXT BIG TREND.
♪♪
HI.
MY NAME IS IRINA BLOK.
AND TODAY I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
YOU ONE OF MY PRODUCTS.
IT'S CALLED FACE‐BLOCK.
I'M LOOKING FOR
A $50,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE OF 30%
OF MY PRODUCT.
(Robert laughs)
SO... FACE‐BLOCK IS
A COLLECTION
OF FASHION SURGICAL MASKS.
(chuckles)
♪♪
IT'S DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE
WITH EDGY SENSE OF HUMOR
WHO WANT TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES.
TAKING SOMETHING...
(Barbara) OH, MY GOSH.
STERILE...
(Barbara) WOW!
AND UNINTERESTING
AS A SURGICAL MASK
AND INFUSING IT
WITH FUN AND CREATIVITY
CREATES
A REALLY UNIQUE PRODUCT.
SEE FOR YOURSELF.
TRY IT ON.
I THINK I'LL PASS.
HE'S THE PERFECT GUY
FOR THIS MASK.
OH, YEAH.
IRINA, HOW DO I PUT IT ON?
JUST...
JUST PUT IT ON.
(O'Leary) DOES IT HAVE
REAL SURGICAL PROPERTIES
IN TERMS OF PROTECTING
AGAINST DISEASE?
THAT'S WHEN
THE INVESTMENT COMES IN.
(Robert chuckles)
(O'Leary) THAT'S WHEN
THE INVESTMENT COMES IN?
DOES IT WORK?
(Robert) DAYMOND,
LET ME SEE YOURS.
(laughs) LOOK AT DAYMOND.
HE'S WEARING IT WRONG.
NO?
HE NEEDS TWO.
(muffled voice)
CAN YOU TALK WITH IT ON?
(laughing)
WHAT'S SO FUNNY?
HEY, LISTEN, I'M TRYING
TO MAKE SOME MONEY HERE.
TELL ME IF THIS WORKS
OR NOT.
SO YOU'RE SAYING
THESE PROTOTYPES ARE NOT MADE
FROM THE TRUE
SURGICAL MASK
THEY'RE NOT.
DESIGN POSSIBILITIES
ARE ENDLESS.
(Barbara) I'M SURE.
SO I SEE FACE‐BLOCK
AT EVERY HOSPITAL.
DO YOU THINK HOSPITALS
MAY HAVE A PROBLEM
PUTTING A PIG SNOUT
ONTO A DOCTOR'S FACE?
(chuckling)
THE HEAD OF
AMERICAN PEDIATRIC BOARD
HAD CONTACTED ME
WHEN THEY SAW THIS MASK,
AND THEY SAID
THEY THINK IT'S GENIUS.
THEY WANT TO HAVE THOSE MASKS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY INTERESTS,
ANY SALES?
IN ONE WEEK
AFTER I LAUNCHED IT,
IT WAS ON FOX NEWS,
"SYDNEY MORNING HERALD,"
I HAD CLOSE TO MILLION HITS
ON MY WEB SITE.
WHOA.
YOU HAD A MILLION HITS
TO YOUR WEB SITE?
CLOSE TO. I HAD 700,000.
BUT IS THAT
BECAUSE SWINE FLU
WAS ALL OVER THE NEWS
FOR TWO WEEKS?
NOW WE DON'T SEE IT ANYMORE.
IT'S AN EPIDEMIC
THAT CAME AND WENT.
YOU NEED A NEW EPIDEMIC
TO GET THAT KIND
OF A HIT PROFILE AGAIN.
SO HOW MANY SALES DID YOU HAVE
FROM‐‐FROM ALL THOSE HITS?
I HAD COUPLE HUNDRED OF SALES,
BUT THAT IS‐‐
WHY ONLY A COUPLE OF HUNDRED
WHEN YOU HAD‐‐
'CAUSE IT'S NOT
A REAL SURGICAL MASK.
BUT, IRINA, THERE'S REALLY
NO COMPANY HERE.
YOU‐‐YOU'RE BRAND‐NEW. YOU JUST
STARTED. IT'S A BRAND‐NEW IDEA.
(Irina) THAT'S RIGHT.
THE QUESTION IS,
IS IT A GOOD IDEA?
IN FOREIGN MARKETS, IRINA,
WHERE THEY WEAR MASKS
MORE OFTEN,
DO THEY DO DESIGNS
ON THE MASKS?
LIKE IN JAPAN, FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY DON'T,
AND I THINK THERE IS
A‐A NICHE OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT.
IS THIS A FASHION STATEMENT,
DAYMOND?
COULD YOU MAKE THIS HAPPEN
ON THE STREET?
NO.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
WHY NOT?
IT'S, UH, SOMETHING
THAT THEY DON'T NORMALLY DO
IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S JUST DOWNRIGHT FREAKY.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M JUST OUT.
IT'S SO FREAKY.
IRINA, IT'S A NOVELTY ITEM,
NOT A SERIOUS ITEM,
AND‐‐AND I JUST DON'T SEE
THE MARKET FOR IT.
SO ON THAT NOTE, I'M OUT.
I'M GONNA STAND WITH KEVIN
AS WELL,
AND I'M OUT
FOR THE SAME REASONS.
I‐I‐‐KEEP DOING IT
AS A SIDE BUSINESS.
DON'T QUIT YOUR DAY JOB.
I'M OUT.
IT'S A UNIQUE IDEA.
THERE'S NO QUESTION.
BUT AS AN INVESTABLE CONCEPT,
IT'S NOT THERE. I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD LUCK.
(Irina) THANK YOU.
MY TARGET AUDIENCE
ARE PEOPLE WHO DARE
TO EXPRESS THEMSELVES
AND WHO HAVE
EDGY SENSE OF HUMOR,
BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S THE SHARKS.
♪♪
MY NAME'S JEFF COHEN,
AND I'M FROM
STEVENSON RANCH, CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN MARRIED FOR 20 YEARS,
AND I HAVE 2 SONS.
(Jeff) WHO WANTS COLESLAW?
UH...
I'VE BEEN A DIABETIC
FOR 15 YEARS,
AND IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO FIND SNACKS THAT TASTE GOOD
THAT WON'T SPIKE
MY BLOOD SUGAR.
OKAY, SO GRAB THE OATS,
AND WE NEED 20 OUNCES OF OATS.
WITH THE HELP OF MY FAMILY,
WE'VE COME UP WITH A HEALTHY
GOURMET DIABETIC PRODUCT
THAT'S NOT JUST FOR DIABETICS
BUT ANYBODY INTERESTED
IN A HEALTHY LIFESTYLE.
AND YUMMY.
I'VE INVESTED A LOT OF
OUR FAMILY'S HARD‐EARNED MONEY
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
GO GET IT.
AS AN ENTREPRENEUR,
MY DREAM'S ALWAYS BEEN
TO DEVELOP A PRODUCT
THAT EVERYBODY LOVED
AND BRING IT TO THE MASS MARKET.
MY FAMILY'S ALL BEHIND IT.
I DON'T WANT
TO DISAPPOINT ANYBODY.
IF I DON'T GET THE INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS,
THAT'S ALL AT RISK.
♪♪
HI, MY NAME'S JEFF COHEN,
AND I'M THE GRANOLA GOURMET.
I'M LOOKING FOR
$175,000 INVESTMENT
FOR A 25% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
BUT BEFORE WE GET STARTED,
I'D REALLY LIKE FOR YOU
TO TRY OUR PRODUCT.
KEVIN, IF YOU'D BE KIND ENOUGH
TO PASS THOSE DOWN.
SURE.
AND I'M HERE TO PRESENT
A GOURMET DIABETIC PRODUCT.
OUR PRODUCT HAS A SLOGAN.
THE SLOGAN IS...
"ENERGY BARS FOR ATHLETES,
DIABETICS & YOU!"
I'VE BEEN DIABETIC
FOR THE PAST 15 YEARS
AND COULD NEVER REALLY FIND
A SNACK THAT BOTH
TASTED REALLY GOOD
AND WOULDN'T CAUSE
MY BLOOD SUGAR TO SPIKE.
OUT OF THAT,
WE CREATED GRANOLA GOURMET.
DID YOU GUYS LIKE THE BARS?
VERY NICE.
VERY GOOD.
THEY'RE ALSO REALLY GOOD
FOR YOU.
JEFF, WHAT EXPERIENCE DO YOU
HAVE IN MAKING GRANOLA BARS?
HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THE FORMULA?
I ACTUALLY WOKE UP, AND MY WIFE
WAS MAKING SOME GREAT MUFFINS.
AND I SAID, "HEY, BABE.
IT WOULD BE SO GREAT
IF WE COULD MAKE SOMETHING THAT
I COULD ACTUALLY EAT SOMETIME."
(sharks laugh)
YOU KNOW WHAT, JEFF? I SAY THAT
TO MY WIFE ALL THE TIME.
(laughs)
WELL, MY‐‐MY SON WAS 15
AT THE TIME,
AND HE SAID,
"YOU KNOW, DAD, LET'S DO THAT.
LET'S MAKE SOMETHING
THAT I LIKE THAT YOU CAN EAT."
AND SO WE SPENT THAT ENTIRE
2‐WEEK HOLIDAY PERIOD
LEARNING WHAT INGREDIENTS
ON THE GLYCEMIC INDEX WERE LOW.
IDENTIFYING THE FACT
THAT IT LOOKED LIKE WE COULD
MAKE A GRANOLA OUT OF THIS,
MY WIFE STARTED
EATING THESE WITH US,
AND SHE GAVE ME
THE GREATEST COMPLIMENT‐‐
"JEFF, YOU KNOW WHAT? THESE,
UH, FRUIT FLAVORED BARS...
THEY'RE OKAY."
JEFF, HOW LONG YOU BEEN MARRIED?
UH, 20 YEARS TODAY.
'CAUSE I'VE BEEN MARRIED
FOR ALMOST 20 YEARS.
ISN'T IT FUNNY
THAT AFTER 20 YEARS,
"OKAY" FROM YOUR WIFE
IS, LIKE, "WHOO!"?
(both laugh)
IT USED TO BE,
"YOU'RE WONDERFUL."
NOW IT'S LIKE, "YOU'RE OKAY."
YOU GET THE GOD'S HONEST
FROM YOUR SPOUSE.
TOO HONEST SOMETIMES.
SOMETIMES.
OUR REAL SUCCESS HAS BEEN IN
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION
OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST NATURAL FOOD MARKET,
WHOLE FOODS.
FRANKLY, WE WORKED REAL HARD
TO GET IN.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
WITH WHOLE FOODS?
WELL, WITH WHOLE FOODS
RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE DOING SOMEWHERE ABOUT
$8,000 OR $10,000 A MONTH.
WHAT ARE YOUR TOTAL SALES?
THAT'S MOST OF OUR SALES.
ARE YOU SELLING
AT ONE WHOLE FOODS STORE?
WE'RE IN 90%
OF THE WHOLE FOODS STORES
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
MARKET.
HOW MANY STORES IS THAT?
UH, RIGHT NOW, THAT'S 24.
ARE YOU GETTING REORDERS?
EVERY WEEK OR TWO WEEKS,
WE'RE IN REFILLING OUR RACK.
FOR A BUSINESS
THAT'S BEEN UP AND RUNNING
LESS THAN A YEAR?
GOOD FOR YOU.
WE'VE ACTUALLY
ONLY BEEN DOING IT
FOR ABOUT SIX OR SEVEN MONTHS.
BUT WHY AREN'T YOU
AT OTHER STORES?
LET'S FORGET THE OTHER STORES
FOR A SECOND,
BECAUSE I LIKE YOUR APPROACH.
YOU GOT INTO WHOLE FOODS.
STEP ONE. THEY GOT BEHIND YOU.
STEP TWO.
TO ME, STEP THREE IS ROLL IT OUT
NATIONALLY TO WHOLE FOODS.
THAT WILL INCREASE YOUR SALES.
AND THEN GO TO OTHER RETAILERS
ONCE IT'S ON A NATIONAL BASIS.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU DONE THAT?
IT REQUIRES CASH.
RIGHT NOW, WE'VE BEEN
BOOTSTRAPPING THE COMPANY
FROM THE BEGINNING.
AND WHY HAVE YOU COME TO US
INSTEAD OF GOING TO A BANK?
I HAD A SOFTWARE COMPANY.
I HAD PERSONALLY GUARANTEED
A LOT OF LOANS
FOR THAT BUSINESS.
AFTER SIX YEARS
OF HAVING RUN IT SUCCESSFULLY,
I GOT STUCK
WITH A NUMBER OF THOSE LOANS
AFTER SELLING SOME OF THE ASSETS
OF THE FIRM AND CLOSING IT.
THAT BUSINESS WENT BANKRUPT
IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
UH, I HAD A PERSONAL BANKRUPTCY
BECAUSE OF IT.
YOU WANT ME
TO GIVE YOU $175,000,
AND I'LL GET 25%
OF YOUR COMPANY,
SO I'D CALCULATE YOUR WHOLE
COMPANY AS WORTH $700,000 NOW
WITH $80,000 A YEAR
WORTH OF SALES.
I DON'T SEE HOW
IT'S WORTH $700,000.
I AGREE
IT'S NOT WORTH $700,000.
HE'S DOING 80 TO 90 GRAND
A YEAR IN SALES.
JEFF, LET'S BE REAL.
YOU WENT BANKRUPT.
THAT WIPED OUT YOUR ABILITY
TO RAISE MONEY FROM A BANK.
THAT'S LIFE.
IT'S NOT MY FAULT.
YOUR BUSINESS
IS NOT WORTH $700,000.
IT'S PROBABLY WORTH
A COUPLE OF HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS RIGHT NOW‐‐
TWO TIMES SALES‐‐
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
FOR ME TO GIVE YOU $175,000,
I'D HAVE TO OWN
YOUR WHOLE COMPANY.
I PUT A NUMBER OUT THERE
THAT I DIDN'T THINK
WAS GONNA BE
AN OUTRAGEOUS NUMBER
BUT WAS SOMETHING
WE COULD WORK FROM TOGETHER.
JEFF, I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
MY TAKE ON THIS RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING
AT YOUR GRANOLA BUSINESS.
IT'S A‐‐TO ME, IT'S
A "ME, TOO" BUSINESS, OKAY?
WHAT IS ME, TOO?
I'VE HEARD YOU SAY THAT BEFORE.
THERE'S 90 OTHER GUYS
DOING IT.
ME, TOO MEANS THERE'S‐‐
ME, TOO. EVERYONE'S IN IT.
OH, ME, TOO! GOT IT.
OKAY, SO IT'S
A ME, TOO BUSINESS. I'M OUT.
I LIKE YOU. I REALLY DO,
AND I HAVE TO BE HONEST.
I REALLY DIDN'T LIKE
THE TASTE OF THEM.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY I'M OUT.
OKAY.
SO YOU'RE GONNA NEED
A LOT MORE MONEY,
AND I'M NOT PREPARED TO DO THAT.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
I DON'T THINK I'LL EVER SEE
A RETURN ON MY INVESTMENT.
SO I WISH YOU LUCK,
BECAUSE I THINK YOU HAVE
A GREAT PRODUCT HERE.
BUT I'M NOT IN IT.
I'M OUT.
SORRY TO HEAR THAT.
JEFF, I UNDERSTAND
YOUR DECISION TO GO BANKRUPT.
IT CLEANS THE SLATE.
BUT IT CARRIES A WEIGHT.
IF I WAS YOUR PARTNER,
AND THE BUSINESS WAS SUCCESSFUL,
WE WOULD REQUIRE MORE CAPITAL,
AND NO BANK IS GOING
TO LOAN YOU ANY MONEY.
THAT CAUSES ME TO PUT UP
MORE CAPITAL AND MORE CAPITAL
AND MORE CAPITAL.
IT'S A FACT. YOU NEED A BANK
AT SOME POINT.
YOU'LL NEVER HAVE
A BANK, JEFF, EVER.
TO ME, YOU'RE RADIOACTIVE.
I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, KEVIN? THERE'S
NOBODY WHO'S RADIOACTIVE.
AND JEFF KNOWS THIS‐‐
THE MEASURE OF A MAN
IS NOT HOW MANY TIMES
YOU GET KNOCKED DOWN.
CRY ME A RIVER, ROBERT.
THE MEASURE OF A MAN
IS HOW YOU GET UP FROM THAT.
THE GUY WENT BANKRUPT.
NOT MY FAULT.
YOU'VE NEVER FAILED?
I DIDN'T GO BANKRUPT,
BECAUSE I KNEW THE COST.
LET ME DEAL WITH JEFF FIRST,
AND THEN I'LL DEAL WITH YOU.
♪♪
YOU'VE NEVER FAILED?
I DIDN'T GO BANKRUPT,
BECAUSE I KNEW THE COST.
LET ME DEAL WITH JEFF FIRST,
AND THEN I'LL DEAL WITH YOU.
SURE. ALL RIGHT.
SO, JEFF, YOU'VE DONE
A VERY GOOD JOB
IN GETTING INTO
A VERY LARGE RETAILER,
AND YOU DON'T SEEM FOCUSED
ON MAXIMIZING
ON THAT OPPORTUNITY.
ONLY FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
WELL, THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU, JEFF.
OKAY.
SAME HERE.
♪♪
OKAY, SO THE GUY HAS
A WIFE AND KIDS,
AND YOU JUST TOLD HIM THAT
HE'S A RADIOACTIVE HUMAN BEING.
PRETTY DAMN TOUGH.
I ASKED THE GUY A QUESTION.
DID HE GO BANKRUPT?
HE SAID YES. I NOW KNOW A BANK
WILL NOT FINANCE HIM, PERIOD.
AND THEN YOU DUMPED ON HIM.
JUST‐‐
I DIDN'T DUMP ON HIM.
I SAID I CAN'T INVEST IN HIM.
HE'S RADIOACTIVE.
HE WENT BANKRUPT.
LET THAT BE A LESSON, ROBERT.
DON'T GO BANKRUPT.
AND THERE ARE A MILLION PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO ARE GONNA
GET THE WRONG MESSAGE
FROM WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
NO, THEY'RE GETTING
THE RIGHT MESSAGE.
THEY SHOULD NOT GO BANKRUPT.
THERE'S A MILLION DEALS
IN THE NAKED CITY.
I'VE FORGOTTEN ABOUT THIS GUY
ALREADY. BRING ON THE NEXT DEAL.
I'M HERE TO MAKE MONEY.
WELL...
THE SHARKS FOCUSED WAY TOO MUCH
ON MY PERSONAL BANKRUPTCY.
THIS IS A GREAT COUNTRY.
WE GET A SECOND CHANCE HERE.
IT'S JUST A SHAME THEY'RE NOT
GONNA BE PARTICIPATING IN MINE.
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS RIKKI FARRAR,
WHOSE BUSINESS WAS INSPIRED
BY HER MOTHER.
♪♪
HI. MY NAME IS RIKKI FARRAR,
AND I'M THE OWNER
OF GOOD GRIEF CELEBRATIONS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
THE SHARK TANK FOR $50,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 25% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY.
SO GOOD GRIEF CELEBRATIONS
IS A FUNERAL CONCIERGE SERVICE.
AS A FUNERAL CONCIERGE COMPANY,
WE'RE HAPPY TO WRITE THE EULOGY,
OFFICIATE THE FUNERAL SERVICE
AND HANDLE
ALL OF THE POST‐FUNERAL
FAMILY GATHERING DETAILS.
THE CELEBRATION OF LIFE MOVEMENT
IS GAINING TREMENDOUS MOMENTUM.
WE OFFER CELEBRATION OF LIFE
PARTY PLANNING.
MICHAEL JACKSON HAD ONE,
RICHARD PRYOR HAD ONE,
BERNIE MAC, MY MOTHER AS WELL.
RIKKI, DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?
YES, I'VE HAD, LAST YEAR,
$11,000 IN SALES.
THAT'S IT?
YES.
RIKKI, HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS IDEA?
I ACTUALLY CAME UP
WITH THIS IDEA
WHEN MY MOTHER PASSED AWAY
TWO YEARS AGO.
SHE HAD ME PLAN HER FUNERAL,
AND SHE KEPT ON SAYING
THAT SHE WANTED TO HAVE
A CELEBRATION OF LIFE PARTY,
AND THAT SHE DIDN'T WANT IT
TO BE SAD WITH A BUNCH OF TEARS.
SO I ACTUALLY PLANNED
AN AMAZING PARTY FOR HER.
WE HAD A DEEJAY.
WE HAD AN OPEN BAR
THAT SERVED
HER FAVORITE DRINKS.
(Harrington) RIKKI‐‐
AND PEOPLE KEPT ON COMING UP TO
ME‐‐I'M SORRY, IF I COULD JUST
ANSWER HIS QUESTION? THANK YOU.
PEOPLE KEPT ON COMING UP TO ME
TELLING ME THAT IT WAS SUCH
A GREAT IDEA AND THAT YOU SHOULD
THINK ABOUT TURNING IT
INTO A BUSINESS.
(Robert) RIKKI, YOU DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH YOUR MOM
PASSING AWAY AND PEOPLE
DRINKING AT A BAR?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IT'S A CELEBRATION OF LIFE.
(O'Leary) ROBERT, WE IRISH
DO THAT EVERY DAY.
IRISH WAKE, YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
I LOVE THIS BUSINESS.
THANK YOU.
PEOPLE ARE DYING TO GET IN.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
LITERALLY.
THERE'S NEVER A BETTER TIME
TO UPSELL
THAN WHEN A FAMILY
IS STRICKEN WITH GRIEF,
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT REALLY
LOOKING AT THE MARGINS ANYMORE.
THAT FITS YOU SO WELL.
THAT SOUNDS
SO MUCH LIKE YOU.
BARBARA,
I'M DEALING WITH FACTS.
THIS IS WHY THE FUNERAL BUSINESS
IS WONDERFUL‐‐
LOTS AND LOTS OF CLIENTS.
THE PROBLEM IS,
EVERYTHING YOU'VE LISTED,
WITH THE EXCEPTION, PERHAPS,
OF THE PARTY CELEBRATION
PLANNING,
IS INCORPORATED INTO MOST
FUNERAL HOME BUSINESS MODELS.
TELL ME WHY YOU THINK
YOU CAN COMPETE
WITH EVERY FUNERAL HOME WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE ONE YOURSELF.
AND THAT'S WHY YOUR SALES
ARE SO LOW.
THE REASON WHY MY SALES ARE
SO LOW IS BECAUSE OF EXPOSURE.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THAT CELEBRANTS EXIST.
OKAY, RIKKI, LET'S ROLE‐PLAY.
SOMEBODY IN MY FAMILY JUST DIED.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW YOU EXIST.
RIGHT.
I'M SITTING DOWN
WITH THE DIRECTOR SAYING,
"I'M STRICKEN WITH GRIEF.
HELP ME GET THROUGH THIS."
AND HE'S UPSELLING ME
LIKE CRAZY. WHERE ARE YOU?
YOU'RE NOWHERE. YOU'RE NOT
EVEN INSIDE THAT ROOM,
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
IN THE FUNERAL PARLOR.
THE BODIES ALWAYS GO THERE
FIRST. THEY DON'T COME TO YOU.
YOU HAVE NO DEAD GUY MAGNET.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I ACTUALLY USE
TO ATTRACT CLIENTS‐‐
I HAVE A THERAPY DOG,
AND WE VISIT HOSPICE
AND NURSING HOMES.
AND AS PEOPLE DIE‐‐
YOU WAIT FOR PEOPLE TO DIE?
THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT WE GET BUSINESS, YES.
(Robert) OH, COME ON.
DOES HE KIND OF SMELL
WHO'S ABOUT TO CROAK?
I WISH HE COULD. THAT WOULD
MAKE IT A LOT EASIER.
DO YOU NOT THINK YOU'RE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
YOU'RE GOING OUT
TO PEOPLE WITH A DOG
TO MAKE THEM FEEL COMFORTABLE...
RIGHT.
SO YOU CAN SIGN
THEIR FAMILY UP FOR THIS DEAL?
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT'S WRONG WITH
IT. SHE'S NOT CHARGING FOR IT.
KEVIN, KEVIN. KEVIN,
JUST SHUT UP FOR A SEC.
NO. THERE'S NO MONEY IN IT.
NO, NO, NO.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
I KNOW YOU DON'T
GIVE A CRAP, BUT‐‐
I DO GIVE A CRAP. SHE'S MAKING
NO MARGIN ON THE DOG.
(Robert) THERE'S A MORE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM
WITH THIS PRESENTATION.
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET IN FRONT
OF PEOPLE IN THEIR MOMENT
OF NEED...
ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEIR GRIEF.
NO, I'M TRYING TO GET BUSINESS.
(O'Leary) LIKE EVERY FUNERAL
HOME DOES, ROBERT, EVERY DAY.
EXACTLY.
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE.
(Robert) I THINK SHE'S A SLICK
BUSINESSWOMAN, AND I THINK,
DEEP DOWN, SHE KNOWS SHE'S
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE.
AND SHE DOESN'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH IT. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DO, AND I DON'T WANT TO BE
IN BUSINESS WITH YOU
FOR THAT REASON.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
♪♪
IT'S A LITTLE
TOO CREEPY FOR ME,
AND I THINK IT'S
A 1‐MAN BUSINESS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT
EXPANDABLE FOR YOU.
OKAY.
SO I'M OUT.
LET ME ASK SOMETHING, RIKKI.
IS THAT YOUR MOM?
SURE. YES, IT IS.
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK SHE
WOULD THINK OF THE BUSINESS?
IF MY MOTHER WAS ALIVE,
I HONESTLY WOULDN'T BE HERE
IN BUSINESS TODAY,
BECAUSE MY BUSINESS
IS A TRIBUTE TO HER.
I THINK HER LOOKING DOWN ON ME
RIGHT NOW,
SHE IS SO IMPRESSED AND AMAZED
AND VERY, VERY PROUD OF ME.
SO ROBERT IS ACTUALLY WRONG
IN THINKING THAT YOU'RE
JUST TRYING TO MANIPULATE
AND COME IN AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT FACT THAT
SOMEBODY'S GRIEVING?
IT'S NOT ABOUT MANIPULATING
AND TAKING ADVANTAGE AT ALL.
SOMEBODY HAS TO OFFICIATE
THE FUNERAL SERVICE.
SO WHY NOT US?
THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THE MONEY HERE.
AT $11,000 IN SALES...
I DON'T SEE MARGINS.
I DON'T SEE PROFIT IN THERE.
BUT I THINK THAT YOU DID
A COMMENDABLE JOB
OF PRESENTING IT TO US
AND GIVING US ALL THE FACTS,
BUT I'M OUT.
RIKKI, I LOOK AT IT KIND OF
AS AN AMBULANCE‐CHASING
TYPE BUSINESS...
IT IS.
AND THAT'S REALLY NOT
THE BUSINESS I WANT TO BE IN...
OKAY.
SO I'M OUT ALSO.
I LOOKED FOR EVERY WAY POSSIBLE
TO FIND A REASON
TO INVEST IN YOU,
'CAUSE I LIKE DEATH.
IT'S INEVITABLE.
THE PROBLEM IS,
YOU'RE NOT MAKING ANY MONEY.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
AND THAT REASON ONLY,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
♪♪
(Harrington) I DIDN'T KNOW
YOU OWN FUNERAL HOMES.
ARE YOU SURPRISED?
I INVEST IN THEM.
LOOK, I'M LOOKING AT HER MOTHER.
SHE'S LOOKING AT ME. YOU KNOW
WHAT SHE'S SAYING TO ME?
"I WISH RIKKI
WOULD MAKE MORE MONEY."
(sharks laugh)
♪♪
HI, I'M RODOLFO SACCOMAN.
AND I'M ALEXIS SACCOMAN,
AND WE'RE BROTHERS
ORIGINALLY FROM BRAZIL.
I'M A THERAPIST,
AND I HAVE A PRIVATE PRACTICE
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M DIRECTOR
OF ONLINE MARKETING
FOR A MAJOR RESORT
IN PALM BEACH, FLORIDA.
WE COMBINED BOTH
OF OUR EXPERTISE
TO CREATE
AN INNOVATIVE BUSINESS
THAT HAS TONS
OF MONEYMAKING POTENTIAL,
BUT ALSO,
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY EVEN,
TO HELP PEOPLE.
WE STARTED IN BRAZIL
AND WERE THERE
PRETTY MUCH UNTIL THE AGE
OF 6 AND THE AGE OF 10.
RIGHT.
AND THEN THAT'S WHEN MY FATHER
MADE HIS BIG BREAK.
HE STARTED AS A FACTORY WORKER
IN BRAZIL.
WORKING HIS WAY
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL,
THEN COLLEGE
AND THEN TWO MASTER'S DEGREE.
HE KNEW THAT HE WANTED ALEXIS
AND MYSELF TO LEARN ENGLISH,
BECAUSE IF WE LEARNED ENGLISH,
EVENTUALLY WE COULD GET
TO THE U. S.
AN INVESTMENT FROM THE SHARKS
WILL JUSTIFY
OUR PARENTS' SACRIFICE‐‐
OVER 14 YEARS SINCE
I LANDED IN THE U. S.‐‐
TO CREATE SOMETHING BEAUTIFUL,
AND FINALLY WE CAN TASTE
A BIT OF THIS AMERICAN DREAM.
♪♪
HELLO. MY NAME
IS RODOLFO SACCOMAN.
AND I AM ALEXIS SACCOMAN.
WE'RE THE FOUNDERS AND CREATORS
OF OUR WEB SITE‐‐
MY THERAPY JOURNAL.
TODAY WE'RE HERE
TO ASK $80,000
FOR A 20% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR BUSINESS.
NOW IF YOU'LL
PLEASE INDULGE US
AND CLOSE YOUR EYES
FOR FIVE SECONDS?
THINK OF SOMETHING
THAT MAKES YOU FEEL GOOD...
SOMETHING THAT
MAKES YOU HAPPY.
$10 MILLION.
(laughs)
(Rodolfo) OKAY.
PLEASE OPEN YOUR EYES.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
IN BUSINESS FOR‐‐
TO GIVE THAT FEELING
TO MORE PEOPLE MORE OFTEN
AND IN MORE PLACES.
WE ARE
REVOLUTIONIZING THERAPY.
WHAT MY THERAPY JOURNAL
OFFERS
IS AN ONLINE
PSYCHOTHERAPEUTIC TOOL.
WE PROVIDE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
AND AFFORDABLE ALTERNATIVE
TO TRADITIONAL THERAPY.
SO, ALEXIS, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PROVIDE AND SHARE
A LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT OUR SOFTWARE DOES?
SURE. CURRENTLY, THE ENTIRE
WEB SITE IS DATA‐DRIVEN.
SO FAR, THE COMPANY
HAS TWO COMPONENTS‐‐
THE FIRST IS JOURNALING
THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO POUR YOUR HEART OUT
IN THE MOST SECURE
OF ONLINE JOURNALS.
THE SECOND COMPONENT
IS THE PROGRESS QUESTIONS
AND THE PROGRESS GRAPH.
IT ALLOWS YOU TO TRACK
ANY EMOTION, BEHAVIOR...
MM‐HMM.
DIAGNOSIS, PROBLEM,
AMBITION, HOBBY‐‐
IT ALLOWS YOU TO TRACK
ANYTHING YOU WANT,
AND IT GRAPHS IT FOR YOU
IN A LINE GRAPH
SO THAT EVERY TIME YOU LOG ON,
YOU GET TO SEE
HOW YOU'RE DOING TODAY
AS COMPARED TO LAST WEEK,
LAST MONTH OR LAST YEAR.
OKAY, THAT'S WONDERFUL,
BUT HOW DO I MAKE MONEY
OFF DEPRESSED PEOPLE?
WE HAVE OVER A THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT HAVE SIGNED UP.
WE HAVE PAYING CUSTOMERS. THIS,
AGAIN, IS MAKING MONEY TODAY.
THERE'S NO OVERHEAD COST.
WHAT ARE THEY PAYING?
IF THEY SIGN UP FOR A FULL YEAR,
IT IS $7.95 PER MONTH.
IF THEY DO A 3‐MONTH PERIOD,
THEN IT'S $11.95 PER MONTH,
AND IF THEY JUST DO
ON A MONTH‐BY‐MONTH BASIS,
IT IS $14.95.
HOW MUCH MONEY
HAVE YOU GROSSED THIS YEAR?
LAST YEAR
WE DID ABOUT $4,000.
BUT DIDN'T YOU JUST
SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT A THOUSAND MEMBERS?
WE HAVE‐‐YES. THIS IS HOW
THE SYSTEM WORKS‐‐
NOT PAYING MEMBERS.
1,120, AS OF TODAY,
HAVE SIGNED UP
FOR A FREE TRIAL.
IT'S A 14‐DAY FREE TRIAL.
OKAY. I UNDERSTAND.
AFTER THE 14‐DAY FREE TRIAL,
THEY HAVE AN OPTION
TO BUY A SUBSCRIPTION.
HOW MANY PEOPLE
TURNED OVER TO BUYING?
10% OF THOSE FOLKS
BECOME A PAYING CUSTOMER.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HIT THE SITE?
WE HAD ABOUT 18,000 PEOPLE
HIT THE SITE.
YOU KNOW THAT'S LOW, RODOLFO.
I COMPLETELY AGREE
THAT IT IS LOW,
THE AMOUNT OF VISITORS
WE HAVE HAD.
WE HAVE INVESTED $125,000
OF OUR LIFE'S SAVINGS
TO CREATE THIS.
95% OF THOSE FUNDS WENT
TO DEVELOP THE SOFTWARE.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THOSE FUNDS
FOR ADVERTISING.
WE DON'T HAVE A P. R. AGENCY.
THE WAY WE HAVE DONE IT
MOSTLY IS WORD OF MOUTH.
I STILL HAVEN'T HEARD
HOW MANY PAYING USERS YOU HAVE.
I THINK AROUND 121 PAYING.
IS NOT VERY MUCH.
THE PERCENTAGE‐‐
I JUST WANT TO PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT IF I MIGHT.
YES.
I LIKE YOU, BUT I SURE DON'T
LIKE THIS BUSINESS IDEA,
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
GUYS,
WITH 120 PAYING CUSTOMERS,
THAT'S A TOUGH ONE FOR ME.
I‐I'M GONNA BOW OUT AND‐‐
LET ME SAY THAT
THIS IS...
THANK YOU.
THE INFANCY.
I'M OUT.
THIS IS THE INFANCY
OF THIS WEB SITE.
WE'RE CURRENTLY
IN THIRD STAGE CONVERSATIONS
WITH AETNA,
THE INSURANCE COMPANY.
THEY HAVE 37 MILLION
PEOPLE WITH‐‐
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
(Robert)
SEE, THAT'S INTERESTING.
THAT'S INTERESTING. NOW YOU'VE
GOT MY JUICES FLOWING.
SURE. WE GOT CONNECTED
TO SOME FOLKS THAT SAW
THE POTENTIAL OF OUR PRODUCT
IN AN INSURANCE WORLD.
SO, RODOLFO,
NOW YOU'RE INTERESTING.
OKAY.
UP UNTIL THIS POINT,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT...
OKAY.
YOU HAD INSIGNIFICANT USERS.
FRANKLY, THE SITE...
REALLY INSIGNIFICANT.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
IT'S REALLY AN ONLINE JOURNAL.
BUT WHO CARES?
IF YOU CAN GET
A LARGE INSURANCE COMPANY...
YEAH, YEAH. I GET THE JOKE.
I GET THE JOKE.
TO PROMOTE THIS AS PART
OF GET‐WELL THERAPY,
WELL, MY FRIENDS,
MY FELLOW IMMIGRANT FRIENDS...
RIGHT.
WE'RE ON TO SOMETHING.
IT'S VERY CLEAR.
A LARGE INSURANCE COMPANY
SIGNS UP...
CORRECT.
PROVIDES THIS TO THEIR MEMBERS‐‐
IN FACT, BETTER SCENARIO‐‐
THEY FORCE THEIR MEMBERS
TO GET INSURANCE TO LOG ON.
EVERYBODY HAS TO PAY YOU
A CERTAIN FEE.
LET ME THROW OUT
AN IDEA TO YOU.
YES.
WHAT IF I GAVE YOU $80,000
FOR 50%?
OKAY.
IS IT CONTINGENT ON AETNA?
BECAUSE I'D BE INTERESTED
IN POTENTIALLY COMING IN
FOR MAYBE EVEN MORE MONEY,
BUT TO ME,
THE COMPANY HAS NO VALUE‐‐
UNTIL THE AETNA DEAL.
NO VALUE... OR ANY OTHER
SIMILAR INSURANCE COMPANY.
I'D WANT TO‐‐
I'D BE WILLING
TO PARTNER WITH YOU,
BECAUSE I THINK THE POTENTIAL
IS VERY INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU STARTED
THE PRESENTATION,
I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST ANOTHER
INTERNET BIRDBRAIN IDEA.
LOTS OF THOSE ARE OUT THERE.
YOU GUYS
ARE NOT CRAZY CHICKENS.
GUYS, I WANT IN ON THIS.
SO, RODOLFO,
HERE'S THE OFFER,
AND, UH, DAYMOND AND KEVIN‐‐
$80,000 FOR 51%
OF THE BUSINESS.
THAT'S THE OFFER.
GENTLEMEN, DID YOU NOTICE THAT
SUBTLE CHANGE THAT HAPPENED
IN THE LAST FEW MINUTES?
WHO ARE YOU?
I JUST WANT TO BRING
YOUR ATTENTION TO IT.
ARE YOU THE OFFER MAKER?
BARBARA. BARB. BARB.
CAN WE HELP YOU?
WHO'S THIS?
I THOUGHT I HAD HEARD 50%.
(Robert) I HEAR A VOICE...
I WANT YOU TO KNOW
I'M HEARING 51%.
BUT I DON'T SEE ANYBODY.
DID YOU CATCH THAT LITTLE 1%?
YEP.
WE'RE CATCHING EVERYTHING.
(Alexis) YES. (laughs)
RODOLFO, MY FRIEND KEVIN
MADE A SUBTLE MISTAKE.
BECAUSE WHAT YOU REALLY NEED,
ALONG WITH THE MONEY,
IS YOU NEED SOME GUIDANCE.
YES.
AND BETWEEN MR. BILLIONAIRE
SELLER OF SOFTWARE BUSINESS
AND MR. INTERNET OVER HERE,
I THINK THAT THERE IS
A TREMENDOUS VALUE ON THAT.
YOU COULDN'T HAVE
BETTER PARTNERS.
LISTEN, COULD WE TAKE
A MOMENT? OKAY?
TAKE A MOMENT. TAKE A MOMENT.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
ROBERT?
YEP.
I DON'T WANT YOU
TO THINK OF ME AS COLD.
YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK
OF YOU THAT WAY, KEVIN.
WHAT DO WE NEED DAYMOND FOR?
♪♪
WHILE THE SACCOMAN BROTHERS
CONFER IN THE HALLWAY,
KEVIN O'LEARY REALIZES
THERE'S A THIRD WHEEL
IN THEIR DEAL.
WHAT DO WE NEED DAYMOND FOR?
IT'S 51%.
WE SHOULDN'T GIVE THE 51%.
HOW ABOUT WE GO IN THERE,
AND AGAIN,
WE WANT TO MAKE
THIS REALISTIC.
YEAH.
WE GO 49%, BECAUSE WE‐‐
WELL, WHAT‐‐WHAT IF
THEY LOSE PATIENCE
AND THEN GO, "I'M OUT,
I'M OUT, I'M OUT"?
I THINK WE HAVE TO THROW
DAYMOND UNDER A BUS.
YOU GONNA LET HIM
SCREW ME LIKE THAT?
I'M NOT SCREWING YOU.
IT'S ONLY FOR BUSINESS, DAYMOND.
HE DOESN'T
NEED YOU IN IT, THOUGH.
HE DOES, UNLESS HE WANTS
TO PAY TEN TIMES MORE.
IF WE KEEP 49%,
I TRUST THAT THEM PLUS US
IS GONNA GROW THIS SO BIG.
CORRECT.
SEE?
OKAY. (makes whooshing noise)
(makes whooshing noise)
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO IT.
(speaks foreign language)
YEAH.
OKAY.
HERE'S OUR SUGGESTION.
HOW ABOUT WE GO 49%/51%?
TO US?
NO, WE KEEP 51%.
YOU KEEP 49%.
BUT WE, WORKING SO HARD
AND BELIEVING IN THIS,
WE REALLY WOULD ENJOY US
KEEPING 51% AND YOU 49%.
AND WE KNOW THAT YOUR EXPERTISE
IS GONNA MAKE OUR VISION
GO TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
LIKE, THE FIVE OF US
TOGETHER ARE GONNA‐‐
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
I HAVE BAD NEWS FOR YOU.
WHILE YOU WERE OUT
OF THE ROOM...
OKAY.
DAYMOND GOT RUN OVER BY A BUS.
HE'S NO LONGER PART OF THIS.
I'M NO LONGER PART
OF THEIR DEAL.
OKAY.
(Alexis)
YOU'RE A SEPARATE DEAL?
YEAH.
UNFORTUNATELY,
WE DON'T NEED HIM.
HE DOESN'T BRING
ANYTHING TO THE TABLE.
I BRING $120,000
TO YOU.
AT 51% FOR YOU?
FIFTY‐FIFTY.
ALEXIS, HERE'S WHAT
I'M GONNA TELL YOU.
KEVIN IS RIGHT. DAYMOND ADDS
NO VALUE TO THIS DEAL.
HE'S NEVER DONE A DEAL
ON THE INTERNET.
WHO'S TRYING TO DO CASH, BABY?
AND HERE'S WHAT I'M GONNA SAY
TO YOU ABOUT YOUR 49/51.
OUT OF THE FOUR OF US HERE
THAT MATTER,
WHICH ONE OF US HAVE EVER BUILT
AND SOLD AN INTERNET COMPANY
FOR A FEW HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS?
MY POINT IS, GUYS,
YOU'RE GONNA GO INTO PARTNERSHIP
WITH TWO GUYS
THAT HAVE MADE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS...
(exhales)
IN THE INTERNET?
GO FOR THIS ONE.
DID YOU COME TO THIS COUNTRY
TO HAVE SOMEBODY CONTROL
YOUR BUSINESS?
YOU GUYS‐‐YOU GUYS ARE GOOD,
YOU KNOW? THIS IS‐‐
ALEXIS, WE'RE GOOD. I DON'T KNOW
WHY DAYMOND IS STILL TALKING,
'CAUSE AS I‐‐
I'M JUST‐‐LISTEN, THESE GUYS
COULD BE MY POTENTIAL PARTNERS,
AND YOU ARE TRYING‐‐
FOR A CORPSE,
HE MAKES A LOT OF NOISE.
YOU ARE TRYING
TO CONTROL THEIR BUSINESS
WHERE I'M OFFERING THEM 50%.
DAYMOND, DO YOU EVEN HAVE
AN OFFER ON THE TABLE?
YES.
WHAT'S YOUR OFFER?
$120,000, FIFTY‐FIFTY.
OH, SO LET ME UNDERSTAND THIS.
YOU'VE OFFERED AN EXTRA $40,000,
EVEN THOUGH YOU'VE NEVER MADE
ANY MONEY IN THE INTERNET SPACE.
FOR THE EXTRA 40 GRAND,
THEY SHOULD TAKE YOUR OFFER?
ALSO IT WAS FIFTY‐FIFTY
VERSUS 51/49.
FIFTY‐FIFTY. YEAH.
(Rodolfo) HERE'S WHAT I KNOW
ABOUT THE INTERNET‐‐
AND, DAYMOND,
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
WE ARE IN AT POSITION
THAT WE NEED YOUR EXPERTISE,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE DONE IT.
AND WE HAVE‐‐WE HAVE ALWAYS
FOLLOW EXAMPLES.
WHAT MAKES, UH, A GOOD STUDENT
IS WHO TEACHES...
MM.
THAT STUDENT.
SO YOU'RE GONNA BE
THEIR EMPLOYEES?
NOT AT ALL. PARTNERS.
WE'RE GONNA BE‐‐
(Daymond) PARTNERS?
PARTNERS.
SO IT'S FIFTY‐FIFTY?
YOU'RE GOING TO TRUST THAT WE'LL
LOOK AFTER YOUR BEST INTERESTS
BECAUSE WE'RE INVESTORS,
AND WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE.
IS IT FIFTY‐FIFTY?
(O'Leary) THAT‐‐SILENCE, PLEASE.
SO WHAT ARE YOU GUYS OFFERING,
FIFTY‐FIFTY?
NO.
49?
IT'S 51/49.
WE'RE PUTTING IN‐‐
YOU WANT THE 51, THOUGH.
YES.
(Robert)
WE'RE PUTTING IN $80,000.
I THINK OUR OFFER'S
PRETTY SIMPLE.
RODOLFO, YES OR NO?
YES.
ALL RIGHT!
(laughs)
WHOO!
(O'Leary) GROUP HUG.
NICE! NICE! (laughs)
(speaking indistinctly)
(man) WHOO!
(stomps foot)
(Alexis) THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
(Robert) CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
(O'Leary)
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THAT.
(Robert) I DO, TOO.
(Harrington) GOOD JOB.
(Barbara) GOOD FOR YOU.
NICELY DONE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY NEED THE GUIDANCE MORE THAN
THEY REALLY NEED THE MONEY.
(Daymond)
OF COURSE, OF COURSE.
I MEAN, IT WAS A SMALL AMOUNT
OF MONEY FOR ANY OF US.
(O'Leary) I GOT A GOOD FEELING
ABOUT THESE GUYS.
I GOT A GOOD FEELING
ABOUT THAT.
YEAH.
IMAGINE THEY WERE GONNA LEAVE
BEFORE THEY MENTIONED
THAT INSURANCE DEAL.
I'M AMAZED.
I MEAN, WHY WERE THEY
HOLDING THAT BACK?
BARBARA,
THAT'S WHY THEY NEED US.
'CAUSE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE FIRST TWO WORDS
OUT OF MY MOUTH
WHEN I WALKED OUT THERE.
YEAH.
BUT FATE INTERVENES,
AND THEY GOT A DEAL.
GREAT STORY. WONDERFUL GUYS.
THANK GOODNESS
WE CAME ON "SHARK TANK."
OUR AMERICAN DREAM
SINCE WE WERE LITTLE KIDS
TODAY BECAME A REALITY,
AND ALL THE WORK
AND SACRIFICE HAS PAID OFF.
AND NOW... WE'RE GONNA SOAR.
THANK YOU, "SHARK TANK."
THANKS. OH.
NEXT WEEK ON "SHARK TANK"...
FOR MOST OF MY ADULT LIFE,
I'VE HAD EXCESSIVE, BAD GAS.
(laughs)
WHY IS THIS COMPANY
VALUED AT $1 MILLION?
THEY'RE JUST JOKING ABOUT THAT.
I'VE ACTUALLY WORKED IN V. C.
IF YOU'VE WORKED
IN VENTURE CAPITAL, THEN MY JOB
IS TO SQUEEZE YOUR HEAD LIKE
A TEENAGE PIMPLE RIGHT NOW.
I CAN'T LOOK AT YOU WITHOUT
PICTURING YOU IN A PIG COSTUME.
WHY DON'T YOU PUT OUT A NUMBER?
NO, I CAN'T NEGOTIATE
WITH MYSELF.
YOU PULL THE LEVER.
I'M GIVING YOU THE POWER.
OH, MY GOD. THIS GUY'S GREAT.
I LOVE THIS GUY.
HE IS. HE IS, RIGHT?